[Music]
homie look what I become
yeah all right we back uh at the set we
are still not back in the the studio
with uh you know the Vault and all that
stuff we got to get back to but we
haven't done a home team for a minute
right it's been a minute since we've
done home team we had uh Chris Cuomo we
had Anthony Weiner who else do we have
there there's got to be the pbd the Dave
Smith or the Dave Smith live that we
have not had a home team we got a lot of
stories to go through
um the stories having to do yesterday we
had a very awkward moment uh we're
having dinner with my chef Alper and all
of a sudden the news shows that uh
President Obama's out you know our
personal chef is found dead and Alpha
quietly left the house
and he says I don't know if I'm safe
here and and I said Albert just hang in
there you know it's it's we don't know
what the story behind it is we don't
obviously we're not a we're going to go
into these crazy stories we got some
clips to show you that explains he was
asking me for numbers for PHP said he
wanted life insurance yeah yeah now it
makes sense but we got a few things Adam
wants to react to what's been happening
with uh Israel's Netanyahu pushes ahead
would vote on judicial overhaul while
Netanyahu warns Israel as on the brink
of a military coup Trump threatens would
be very dangerous if Jack Smith sends
him to jail in new interview the santis
doubles down on claimed that some blacks
benefited from slavery this I don't know
if you saw the story wapo someone
thought it was a good idea to double
down on that the 911 Obama you know
phone call Chef middle deny drowning
we'll talk about that you may want to
know who Walter scheibe is it's a former
White House Executive Chef who also died
from drowning in 2015 and maybe it's
like a you know thing you should tell
people if you're thinking about being a
chef for the White House skip that job
interview like go go to a different
restaurant but don't do it New York City
agrees to pay 13.7 million dollars to
George Floyd protesters there's a bunch
of business stories we got to go through
Tom U.S home prices still face a steep
and sustained decline this year
Economist warns home sales Fall as
would-be buyers face High rates low
Supply existing home sales Fall Again
amid worsening Supply shortage
then after a pause a U.S fed likely to
hike interest rates to 22-year high
uh-oh and then why the FED isn't ready
to declare Victory on inflation
inflation yet and there's a saying Bank
been freed story about his defense
lawyers with paying paying them 10
million dollars of misappropriate FTX
funds I know you reported on this a
couple months ago on valuetainment.com
which is a great article there's a story
there being an Insider we got to talk
about vivec he's making a lot of noise
there's some stories about RFK that
snapped at Debbie Wasserman Schultz you
are slandering me uh what else we got
couple woke stories this one's kind of
weird I don't know if you saw this one
or not school districts that allowed
people to have their kids banned out opt
out of lgbtq lessons now are saying you
can no longer opt out your kids they
banned it because too many families
opted out we'll talk about this sounds
like mandates yeah weird Villa Mulvaney
is now looking for speaking
opportunities at schools we'd like to
effectively eliminated from Harvard Area
Middle School because too many white and
Asian students were taking it and
Americans confidence in higher education
has declined sharply I don't know why
okay before we get into the Articles and
the stories here uh gang we got our
vault conference coming up Co tickets
have sold out uh founder tickets have
sold out executive tickets have sold out
the only thing that's left is platinum
in general I'm sure you've seen these
ads all over the place with myself Tom
Brady Mike Tyson will guderra down the
street in Miami at the Diplomat that'll
be happening I think in six weeks Mario
is telling me the event's going to sell
out this week if you haven't yet
registered with every crazy thing that's
going on right now this is the type of
tap of an event you want people
constantly tell me about how do we do
this in this economy how do I handle
this this is an event where you come
through we went through the manual
yesterday 200 Pages for three days we're
gonna go through a 200 Page manual
here's a crazy thing
there's going to be a lot of celebrities
that are taking and attending the ball
conference just to attend it for Content
themselves I can't give names it's it's
based on their invitation when when they
show up are you going to see some people
that are also attending the Vault uh if
you haven't yet registered I think this
is going to sell out this week Rob let's
put a link below for people that want to
get registered for the vault if you buy
one ticket right now second one is 50
off the link will be below uh get
registered you your spouse your business
partner spend three days together in
Miami anyways let's get right into it
okay so business topics is what I'm
going to get into first Vinnie be ready
I'm ready to go U.S home prices still
face a steep and sustained decline this
year Economist warns
there we go so Economist Kieran Clancy
from Pantheon macroeconomics warns that
the U.S housing market is on the verge
of a steep and sustained decline in home
prices contrary to the belief of a
recovery Clancy argues we are baffled by
the emerging narrative because it isn't
recovering Clancy emphasizes the crucial
need for improved affordability in the
housing market true recovery he points
out that affordability has declined with
the median single family house price
surging 10 percent to 350 in the second
quarter resulting in the highest debt to
income ratio since 2007 to achieve a
genuine recovery Clancy States home
sales can't recover until affordability
improves which requires lower mortgage
rates or filing home prices or both he
highlights that the housing market is
shifting from a collapse in demand and
sales to a phase of falling prices and
housing related consumption time what is
going on with real estate I keep getting
guys telling me I told you the mark
crash is not here I told you real
estate's gonna be fine I told you it's
not going to go down what's really going
on with real estate well I'm hearing a
lot of that too but we have to remember
we're living in South Florida and we've
had a huge influx in demand and all
those people moving here remember the
we're hearing in Florida what do we got
we got like uh uh they said 900 from
California 900 a week something like
that 900 a week moving to Florida and so
what's happened is in Florida the prices
are not dropping down because you still
have a lot of cast buyers from the
Northeast that have come down here
holding it but in the rest of the United
States it's just not affordable and
remember Pat you knew about this because
right at the time you were founding
um PHP remember 09 we had just got
through that area where back end ratio
39 38 now 45 is fine Nina no income no
assets no problem well that's not quite
on the table here but right now we don't
have enough uh Supply not enough people
are willing to put their house on on the
market in in the United States that is
still a fact and so with the limited
Supply prices have moved very slowly and
with the interest rates which were
almost eight percent but they dropped
back like six point seven five seven
percent
um a week ago that is keeping keeping it
there and so it's artificial and so as
soon as either of those moves Pat we get
a little more Supply or the rates go
down prices are coming down and that's
what everybody is saying is this is an
artificial scaffolding right now we have
about a million houses on the market and
remember a couple weeks ago pbd podcast
last time we did home team remember we
looked at the normal inventory is like
three and a half four million houses and
it was easily fifty percent or less of
what's normal so what's going on right
now is the high interest rates and the
low Supply because people don't want to
sell their house even if they have to
move for their job they'd rather Airbnb
the old house with a nice low interest
rate and then rent in the new place and
so so we are living on the edge of a
snap or housing it maybe it's not going
to crash through the floor but it's
going to drop and that's what this
economist is talking about and I think
he is absolutely correct you don't see
it right now especially in South Florida
where there's other things at play but
it's going to move so here's so Rob can
you pull up the Twitter tweet I just
sent you uh I I posted this yesterday uh
uh Barry Habib sent me an article I took
a look at it went through the whole
thing very interesting data and then I
posted this I said that you know because
a lot of people are asking a question
about why people aren't selling or
buying a house 92 percent of Americans
have a mortgage right now below six
percent there you go 92 and what's the
current 30 Euro fixed Tom what's the
current 30-year fixed right right now
six seven eight to seven and a quarter
good credit half a million dollars six
seven eight no Thirty Year fixes 7.6 the
15-year fix is 6.8 percent as of today
seven and a half percent is a thirty
year fix so if 92 percent of Americans
have mortgage under six percent no no
zoom out so I can read it right yeah I
appreciate the respect but I can't go
zoom out I don't have those eyes Rob I'm
44. there you go so zoom in is what I
need my English is up so so 92 Americans
have a mortgage below six percent wow if
they want to refi right now so imagine a
salesperson comes up and says hey Johnny
why don't we refinance your mortgage you
got six percent right now I can get you
seven and a half percent 61 are below 4
23 percent have a mortgage below three
percent by the way if you're watching
this airbnb's baby they're not letting
go of those if you're watching this and
you're comfortable about it post your
interest rate in the comments section
I'm curious so why would what would
cause people to start buying and selling
number one Americans running out of
savings this is a very interesting data
in 2020 collectively we had three three
trillion dollars in cash at the bank
2021 and one to two and a half trillion
you could look at the drop off from 21
to 22. it dropped off to 686 billion in
cash as of April we have 800 billion
dollars we went up slightly but as
saving decreases that Panic could cause
owners to sell at a lower price to take
their Equity out number two unemployment
3.6 some of us was going to go to 10
like 08 hasn't happened yet the market
expected unemployment to Skyrocket if
Powell kept increasing rates we haven't
seen that the third one is probably the
most important one Congress has more
power than Powell every time Powell
increased the rates to help address
Obsession the government has with
overspending the last 14 years below
interest rates the whole economic
expansion they say 128 months it wasn't
128 months it was like 150 months if you
take covet out that was going to go for
150 months of cheap money Congress
undermined it by delaying the time bomb
that was coming to Next Generation so
what will happen with a massive crash in
real estate I don't think so maybe
certain Pockets here's the point no
politician or majority of Congress has
the brass to do what actually is best
for America there's a zero percent
chance that that'll happen because the
right thing to do is to find following
yesterday Brandon and I are doing a uh
episode on uh Hospital cost okay it's
something nobody talks about and what's
happened with the price of Hospital
costs per hundred dollars of what it
costs the hospital to charge they're now
charging four hundred and forty dollars
okay it used to be 200 in 1995 1998. so
that two hundred dollars is not 400 400
if somebody asks you a question right
now how much would a bypass surgery cost
you know what the answer is no one will
tell you a bypass they did a serger they
did a a survey calling a hundred and one
different hospitals asking what is a
bypass heart bypass what does a surgery
cost nobody gave him the answer half of
them gave the answer it ranged between
forty four thousand to four hundred and
eighty thousand dollars okay from 44 to
480 on a bypass surgery for your heart
then we went a little bit deeper and we
saw the Medicare and Medicaid so the
Medicare Medicaid that we're taking care
of the elderly folks
the the folks that are actually getting
the benefits they pay little to nothing
the people that are getting the benefits
or the people that are not paying
anything into it only contribute for six
percent of the actual cost for Medicare
or Medicaid guess who's paying the other
94 The Working Man who's doing their
part they're paying for Medicare
Medicaid what's the moral of the story
here the right thing for us to do with
Medicare Medicaid Social Security you
know what the right thing is for us to
do
we got to change it yeah we can't
continue like this because right now the
way we're looking at Medicare Medicaid
the idea is well let the younger
generation pay for it they're supposed
to pay for Baby Boomers I'm sorry this
is not a responsible thing to do guys we
can hear you guys I don't know what's
going on are you guys having issue it's
it's a lot of uh so the whole thing with
Medicare Medicaid Social Security if the
younger generation keeps having to pay
for it they're going to go bankrupt the
older generation the traditionalists the
Baby Boomers are sinners saying oh we
got to get the benefits but why isn't
anybody wanting to change the benefits
of Medicare Medicaid ain't nobody going
to get reelected nobody going to get
reelected what does this have to do with
interest rates same exact thing
the right thing for us to do right now
is to keep the rates high for a long
time have a small little market
correction happen but that's not going
to get anybody to get reelected we have
to print more money and put it in the
bank and we have to print more money to
put in the economy and people are
sitting there saying forget about what
Powell is doing so my thoughts on what's
going to happen with real estate is we
may see a small little adjustment here
and there in different you know pockets
of America
Tom I don't necessarily see a big crash
coming with real estate anytime soon
no I see the Drop In Pockets you
summarized it there and that's why I
talked about South Florida has got some
things here because of the massive
demand and the number of people here I
don't see it removing a lot in South
Florida but there are already markets
where it is moving and it's you it's the
move markets where the underlying
structure is also there people moving
out of San Diego people moving out of
California it's interesting that you
bring up the Medicare and the Medicaid
you know entitlement programs obviously
the big debate over the last decades
have been the Social Security do we
extend the age do we extend the age
limits you see what's going on in France
right now with all the protests they
want to extend
um their version of Social Security what
uh what are the ages Tom they wanted
people to work five years longer you
have the older people saying we don't
want to work this long we have the
younger people saying get the hell out
of here already it's I mean the reality
is this people are living longer and
that I mean I'm in the longevity market
so I understand it's uh it's an
interesting dilemma what they do with
Medicare Medicaid and as you said they
just want to kick the can down the road
just like they do with the debt ceiling
nobody wants to be the politician that
comes in and says blow it all up that's
not what we're doing here fun
interesting that you bring up the the
rising costs in healthcare the only
thing that I think that has increased to
that amount has been the cost of college
right we've done many conversations
about how
the the cost of college has skyrocketed
4x5x10x but is your education that much
better I would like to know how it works
in the medical field
um when it gets when it comes to
mortgages here's how I see it Tom
brought up a good point about supply and
demand obviously in Florida everyone's
moving down here we've seen people
moving to Miami Naples uh Fort
Lauderdale Boca Palm Beach everyone
Florida Jacksonville supply and demand
the way I look at it is it's actually a
different terminology that I would use I
would use I would use cheap versus
expensive so if you went to go buy a
house you know four years ago the
interest rates were the lowest of all
time you know below three percent two
point nine six percent we we all have uh
the ability to remember pre-covered and
you're like all right cool the average
cost of a house back then was 250 275
interest rates are below three all right
cool what's going on now well the
average cost of a house in America today
is 300 50 freaking Grand all right so
they've gone up 7 500 Grand and now
interest rates have gone from
essentially three percent to six seven
percent so if you're the average guy if
you're Vinnie you're me we're just like
yeah this isn't a good deal and it just
like doesn't make sense unless you need
to it's very the fact you said that 92
percent yeah of Americans have an
interest rate
below six percent who the hell would
want to sell at this point no nobody's
going to want to sell no and by the way
I'll say this last part before we go
into the next story is uh home prices
fall as would-be buyers face High rates
low Supply this is Wall Street Journal
existing home sales in June declined 3.3
percent compared to previous month
reaching the slowest sales Pace since
January the national medium exists in
home prices fell point nine percent from
a year earlier to 410 second highest
level on the record the average rate for
30-year fixed right now 6.78 in the
South existing home prices fell by 5.4
percent and in the west 5.1 percent and
our 1.08 million homes for sale under
contract at the end of June unchanged
from May and down 13.6 percent from
previous year the number of new listings
in June decreased decreased that's the
kicker decreased by 26 compared to the
previous year
would somebody sell a house right now so
unless why would somebody buy a house
yeah I'm not buying that's another
question it's but but it's the stalemate
believe it or not it's more why would
somebody sell a house right now right
why would somebody sell your house right
now I got a low rate I can rent this out
I don't have to worry about it my
payment is good I don't have a reason I
guess the only reason you would sell is
if you would go to rent
meaning like all right I've had this
house I've had two kids they're out of
the house I'm 60 years old I no longer
need a four bedroom house me and my wife
will go get a little two-bedroom condo
we'll take the millions what's that
increase needs to you know income needs
to increase for it to make sense people
are not making more money it's not like
all of a sudden your income is going to
go up 25 a year it's just not going to
happen so what's going to happen only to
people that can afford can buy only the
black rocks are going to go buy the
entire Marketplace knowing and then
we're going to be a renters market for a
decade or two this this is the part that
when you go look at cycles of real
estate the last however many decades
there are many seasons where we went
through a decade of being a renter's
Market people just didn't want to buy
there are many decades where we're like
yeah I'm good I don't need to buy why
would I buy a gold renter and then all
of a sudden boom it became buyer's
market and then again seller's market
and then renters markets so it's either
a seller's market it's a buyer's market
or it's a renter's market today it's
none of the above except what is it
today no it's probably renting today
what are you going to do to buy there's
no reason to buy today because it's not
like you're gonna well long-term real
estate it's gonna do fine it's a
non-duper it's a duplicate
non-duplicatable asset that can increase
your net worth but Tom you look like you
were dying to say yeah no the the last
item on this is this is this cycle is
being Complicated by the impact of
Airbnb because people are able to rent
houses that have low interest rates and
I was reading it only takes about nine
rental days a month to cover the house
so if my job forced me to move from
Bedminster New Jersey to Raleigh North
Carolina because that's where I had to
find the job and with covet and
everything I had to work and so I moved
and I don't sell my house in Bedminster
all I have to do is get eight Airbnb
nights out of it and I can cover that
three percent mortgage that situation
and the platform Airbnb did not exist in
08 or 9 or in 1214 very good point so so
so people so sellers reduces the supply
sellers have more options that I'm like
I don't need to sell it right now so
Airbnb is indirectly impact on the
market where Realtors don't have enough
Supply to sell by the way Realtors must
not like Airbnb or would a great realtor
sell a house saying look well if it
doesn't work out just put it on Airbnb
you're going to be fine so maybe there's
a different way of selling it today
Realtors hate Airbnb guys I want to have
to go to a quick uh sponsor I want to
give a quick shout out to Masterworks uh
gang if there's one thing I can tell you
by talking to a lot of different people
right now with clients that we work with
there's a lot of people that have been
taking advantage of Masterworks within
our community simply because of
alternative assets and what's been
happening with art I've given these
numbers before but I'll read it to you
and equally weight SMP has only added a
measly 1.8 year-to-date as a result
there's huge interest in alternative
assets our sponsor Masterworks art
investment platform it's a genius easy
way to get into the art meaning if you
want to buy 10 million dollar Picasso or
Banksy you can't afford to do it you can
do it through banks through Masterworks
and you buy a share of it what these
guys are doing is absolutely genius
there was a record break in your 22 for
auctions and at the same time you know
this is happening while a lot of people
are not really concerned with what's
taking place so if you're somebody
that's you know you're saying Pat I
wouldn't mind getting into art but I
can't afford to buy that stuff
Masterworks would be the perfect company
for you as of June 21 they have 740 000
users with 750 million dollars of assets
under management my suggestion click on
the link below subscribe to Masterworks
see what they have going on and if
you're comfortable with the risk
everything is regulated properly it
registered with the
proper organizations if you want to get
involved start investing into some more
artwork with Masterworks again the
Link's going to be below so Adam you
were going to say something about this
whole real estate story before we wrap
up next one you know you seem pretty
dialed in the on the Airbnb thing
obviously you could just rent your home
that's easy how many have you have you
done any case studies on Airbnb because
I've Airbnb in my apartment before
it's not that easy to do man I mean it's
like I'm not saying that's super
difficult but I just don't know how many
people are actually doing the Airbnb
what kind of stats do you have is it one
percent of homes is it ten percent of
homes what do we know on that
I'm gonna dive in even deeper on the
stats I don't have that in front of me
right now but the points the points that
were made was in certain markets they're
able to keep that home in that low
mortgage and Airbnb is helping them do
it and they only have to get about eight
nine nights of rental out of that point
one point two Realtors and realtor
groups and realtor companies like
Compass are actively supporting
neighborhoods to change zccnr's zoning
Covenant codes and restrictions also
known as homeowners association to
prevent rentals and in South Florida you
can see some uh communities walk in now
you realize you cannot rent for two
years now South Florida has been a um a
transitory Market the things we call
snowbirds or people that come down for
about five and a half to seven months
and you know get get the rheumatism and
arthritis out of the Northeast uh cold
and that sounds like ageism Tom I don't
know I don't appreciate that not ageism
it's freaking arthritis the um the and
now now you know you used to be able to
rent your home but there's certain
places that when you buy a home you
can't rent for two years so there's a
bunch of forces here I'm going to dig in
deeper on this okay and maybe you and I
could you guys got some stats here so so
it says there's Airbnb has roughly 5.6
million active listings in 220 countries
and 60 UH 60 of its users are
millennials meanwhile another article
says 85 percent of the hosts are in
America 85 of the hosts are in U.S and
Airbnb is a you know 70 80 billion
dollar company so it's not like it's a
small company the average host earned
thirteen thousand eight hundred dollars
last year in 2021 there's a thousand
bucks a month which is a thousand bucks
a month it's not a lot of crazy not
money but if you've got a if you have a
half million dollar house and you have a
three percent mortgage that's almost
covering yeah that's almost covering so
again it's another out for a home in
order to say I'm gonna go this direction
I'll tell one quick story if you don't
mind I used to do Airbnb in my apartment
in downtown Miami and obviously Miami is
a very transitory place people are
coming and going we have massive events
every time I would go like any time
there was a massive event like Ultra or
rolling loud or Miami music week or the
Super Bowl
I'm a single dude I can kind of keep it
moving keep it grooving I can just rent
out my place for a thousand bucks a
night boom make five grand on a weekend
uh but most people can't do that
especially have kids you have families
so I've used Airbnb I think it's awesome
I've used it I just don't know how many
families are truly moving their kids
getting out of there you know doing that
whole thing unless they're transplanting
moving like you said from New Jersey to
Florida and they have their place of but
if that's the case I would just rent out
my place so let's dive into this thing
let's talk about salmon and I was just
going to say Pat like I was quiet
throughout this whole exchange housing
and everything I personally I'm gonna
I'm gonna get with my constituents but I
do concur with every everything you guys
are talking about I concur I'm 100 on
board there wasn't one thing that I was
like in my head like I don't believe in
that so okay you guys dig deep more on
the other thing and then we'll we'll
Circle back with you because yesterday
we were very concerned about the
cataclysmic drop and the internal rate
of return I couldn't even eat my
appetizer couldn't even eat my appetizer
it was this disgusting it was just
terrible
damn sweat Sam bankman freed is paying
his defense lawyers with 10 million
dollars of misappropriated FTX funds uh
the founders allegedly being uh accused
of paying them with that funds FTX faces
financial difficulties and enter chapter
11 bankruptcy proceedings last November
questions have been raised about the
funding Bank bank
bankman Freed's defense and the
complaint alleges that he transferred 10
billion dollars of ftx's U.S exchange
account to his own name and then gave
the same sum to his father's FTX account
which has been used to finance as
criminal defense Tom what is going on
here with SPF so we covered this on
valuetainment.com or a little bizdoc
story on entertainment.com after I found
a couple blurbs that were in a longer
Forbes article where they have been
covering all of the investigation where
the remember when the first paratroopers
from the government came in and the
first thing they wanted to know is where
the flip that all this money go they
found the transfers to Alameda remember
that whole chapter and every day there
was a headline where the money went Sam
bankman freed awarded himself
um you know like
selling his own shares and awarded
himself 10 million which was really
investor money and here's what he did
Pat he took a one-time
lifetime exemption on a pass-through
inheritance to his father so he filled
that you know what I'm talking about
Adam or you can do the one-time like
skip generation he took it this was 10
million tax free that went to his dad
through an elaborate trust his dad was
holding it and now his dad is wiring
payments to the law firm big guy and so
this is what so when people say
misappropriated they're they're careful
not to use the word illegal because he
is hiding behind this where this was
this was just out of curiosity Tom just
a legal question so if a guy does this
in business he faces going to jail for
for a long time right if he does this
now here's a question trick question for
you not that this will ever happen well
what if let's just say somebody has more
power than capitalism let's just say
you're like a vice president okay of a
country or maybe you become a president
and you're able to use your powers to
kind of you know get money to come into
the father brother things like that what
kind of consequences will that person
face if they're working for the
government
well probably depends on if they
appointed the attorney general or they
appointed judges and things they could
probably rig it but I would probably do
in that kind of a case I do something
simple like maybe have somebody maybe do
artwork or sculptures and sell it to
people at an over-inflated price so now
now it's it was an art sale it was just
an art sale and maybe this maybe if
someone bought some art and you thought
they were a nice person maybe make them
like ambassador to China or something
because they're a nice person well
listen let me just transition into the
next story Hunters uh Hunter Biden's
Gallery sold uh first Sons artwork to
Major Democratic donor appointed to
prestigious Commission wait a minute
wait that's me that's my idea
Biden's artwork has generated at least
1.3 million dollars in sales with one
buyer being a prominent Democratic donor
appointed by President Joe Biden to a
prestigious commission the buyer
Elizabeth Hirsch naphtali a real estate
investor from Los Angeles was appointed
to the commission for the
pre-preservation of America's Heritage
abroad in July of 2020 to eight months
after Hunter Biden's first art opening
naftali's has a history of significant
donations to the Democratic causes
including over 200 thousand dollars to
the Biden Victory fund during the 2020
election cycle and more than thirty
thousand dollars to the Democratic
National Committee this year another
buyer acquired Hunter Biden's artwork
for 875
000 but their identity remains
undisclosed but in all honesty have you
seen the artwork like you know when
people are on drugs and they're on crack
you should see how beautiful like his
Strokes are we get a glimpse of it have
you seen any of his art look at that
that is crack like you are on crack and
your brain is somewhere else I mean
besides having sex with the underage
girls
is that one of them
click the journey home
this is the journey home for me I mean
you got to be respectful he didn't cross
the line
he stayed in the line I will say this if
anybody
abstract on crack a lot of artists are
known to use DMT yeah maybe use some
acid explore the space a little bit some
smoke marijuana alcohol he's smoking
crack no crack does amazing things these
days it's actually not that bad let me
and I said this Pat on my show ask you a
question do you actually think he did
all these drawn himself or do you think
someone else is doing it and putting it
up there like is this that's all his Pat
is this all his work yes
to be fair it actually looks yeah I'm
not trying to knock it let's fact check
that though I'm I have serious doubts
yeah he probably I'm with you
is it like it you know how they say
there's a Ghost Rider is it Like a Ghost
Rider it might be yeah well I'll tell
you what you know Dave Chappelle on
original
Dave Chappelle Show Rick James famous he
said cocaine's a hell of a drug seems
like crack is a hell of a drug to help
you whoever bought this in there
showing it off like are they walking on
like hey girl hey
we looked at a house
um recently I I I'm gonna give it away
if I give the details don't you agree
anyways I'm gonna say this was a very
very one of the most powerful men in
America we looked at this house how long
ago was this Tom Vinny's house yeah no
less than a month like less than a
minute okay the house let's just say the
house is like 150 100 million dollar
house okay you know I'm gonna just so
we're going to looking at the house and
it's a possibility we like the place
in the bedroom you go in to see how much
the step this type of stuff has value if
I say they're gonna know who it I can't
even say what it is right honestly I'm
being honestly asking I don't want to
say whose house
when we went in that master bedroom
the biggest wall had a
piece of art is how I'm gonna put it
okay that is maybe 12 feet long 10 feet
would you agree like it's 10 feet long
it's it's a it's a it's a it's a little
bit this is 16 so it's a little bit
smaller than this and on the bottom it
says who gave
this to them and it came straight from
the White House from President Joe Biden
and this person is one of the biggest
donors to the campaign okay it was it's
a massive number that the number's not
200 or 400 that's a real number artwork
it was only three colors I don't want to
say I don't so so anyways the point
being I really actually don't want to
say what it is so the point being people
will put the stuff on the wall okay when
you go look at crazy homes Art's being
put it was so funny because Nicole uh
Sam's a girl was with us and wanted the
Arts in a room
what what oh yeah yeah one of the art
pieces in a room it looks so out of
whack Art's not like you know it's not
for everybody or you have to kind of
like it Nicole looks at and tells the
wife says oh wow is this the grandkids
made this no
says she says no this is from a very
famous artist oh my God
oh my God second couple million dollars
Nicole's just trying to be innocent like
you know
but she was like incense she said this
is a calacamos from New York yeah yeah
I'm so sorry yeah so so to Art you have
to know the art community is not
necessarily looking at what you see it's
a very different so in that side I will
defend you know whatever the Art's gonna
look like it's the eye of the beholder
essentially yeah you've been to Art
basil in Miami yes every year I've been
there for the last
10 years or whatever yes you'll walk
down these galleries these aisles this
art and you're like I wouldn't pay a
penny for that
but this over like it is in the eye
Beauty's in the eye of the beholder and
it's there was the famous most famous
piece of art that I remember in the last
couple years was that banana taped to
the wall did you see this one that was
not just any banana though what kind of
banana what's it from Publix
it's like who the hell is buying this
banana on the wall but it was like the
hottest thing at the gallery oh there it
is right there but the best the best
documentary path that I saw just really
really fast was the Salvador Mundy
documentary where they found if they
thought they think it was what was sold
to MBS in uh Saudi Arabia I think it was
like five how much was it a million yeah
400 million dollars because they thought
it was a uh uh Picasso might have been
but do you know the history of that
thing of the actual 1948 what happened
to it and it was originally brought for
like ten thousand dollars and then all
of a sudden he gets it appraised by a
guy and says nope it's all 15 million
bucks and it gets sold for 100 million
and six months later for 400 million 100
million a documentary anyways I mean the
point is the SPF what he's doing where
he's at
um I love your Picasso story you always
tell by the way which one's a Picasso
story about the guy he wanted to do the
artwork yeah it was an incredible story
it's a great story of uh what this guy
did no you know what they say this is
this is why if you're gonna buy art or
baseball cards people would come up to
and they'll say pal what do you think
about this card the guys it's worth five
thousand dollars I said is it graded no
I don't buy anything that's not graded
the only cards I buy that are not graded
is when the pack opens up right in front
of me okay that's that's what I do now
some people may say that's not the right
way of doing it because when it's graded
an organization PSA tells you this is a
mint card this is a perfect card this is
a pristine card so with art you want to
buy from places like Masterworks and
other places that they're telling you
we've done the due diligence the
responsibility of being authentic is on
who it's on that organization that's in
short 70 of art sold in a Marketplace is
fraud wow can you pull up the percentage
by the way what percentage of art is
fraud what percentage of art that sold
is fake it's a massive back in the days
people you said yeah there you go 40 to
70 of the Art Market is the range of
forgery does that include nfts because
that'd be 98 listen you know a lot of
people that made a lot of money in nfds
and they're quite all they're talking
about is kindness right now
that's the whole difference let's
continue let's continue on what's going
on here so look this this is the problem
when you start impeaching for no reasons
you're about to be impeached two to four
years later and it's kind of taking
place right now uh Geo peers demand
Biden's impeachment after Hunter's
ex-business partner reveals alleged
calls must be held accountable this is a
New York Post story if you can go to
page four Rob if you want to put the
story up as well so people can see it
so uh uh uh okay there you go
Republicans demand President Biden's
impeachment after allegations of
frequent phone calls with foreign
business associates through his son
Hunter Biden rep Jim Banks stated House
Republicans should initiate impeachment
proceedings against President Biden
accusing him of enriching his family
through personal influence uh Senator
Ron Johnson commented we've known about
uh President Biden lied about not
discussing Hunters overseas business
dealings that video was going viral
yesterday it certainly wouldn't surprise
me to learn he was far more involved the
IRS agent's testimony alleging Joe
Biden's blocked tax brought charges
against Hunter and evidence of Biden's
meetings with foreign Associates further
fueled the impeachment calls
representative Nancy mace highlighted
another whistleblower Devin Archer will
directly tie Joe to the bribery scheme
in Ukraine if you can pull up that video
of him saying a few years ago I didn't
do any of that Tom when he see the story
what do you think about with what's
going on here are we actually going to
see an impeachment with Biden the way we
did with Trump if we're holding Biden on
this to the same standard as we held
Trump there's actually
that it's it's equal the evidence is
equal and Trump made remember Trump was
impeached twice so I'm talking about the
Ukraine phone calls you take a look at
the Ukraine phone calls and what he did
he he says hey he should be impeached
and we're going to impeach him and they
did impeach him because he made phone
calls to Ukraine and said hey we can do
a deal and certain things can happen
here
and now Biden and Hunters Hunter bidens
as partner Devin Archer is providing
this evidence that hey you know what we
made phone calls and we said hey let's
cut a deal here this is what we'll do
it's the same thing so if you impeach
Trump you have to on a Ticky tack then
you gotta impeach Biden yes guess what
though Pat to answer your it's 100
nothing is going to happen to him and
here's my question too how many whistles
are going to have to be blown to
something like every week whistleblower
here IRS will support FBI whistleblowers
nothing is going to happen in this Devin
Archer guy yeah he was supposed to
testify yesterday this is his third time
he canceled third time he's subpoenaed
to go to Congress he said nope and
canceled what's going to happen to him
nothing zero the left is winning the
right barks that's it that's the
righteous and the love gets away with
murder he's nothing's gonna happen to
him he's going to do his whole full four
years this is this is Peter Ducey and
Biden a couple years ago play this clip
here's what I know I know Trump deserves
to be investigated he is violating every
basic Norm of a president you should be
asking him the question why is he on the
phone with a foreign leader trying to
intimidate a foreign leader if that's
what happened that's appears what
happened you should be looking at Trump
Trump's doing this because he knows I'll
beat him like a drum and there's usually
the abuse of power and every element of
the the presidency to try to do
something to smear me everybody looked
at this and everybody's looked at it and
said there's nothing there ask the right
question
it's interesting couple points seems
pretty cognitive there so the decline is
pretty apparent over the last few years
yeah uh at the same time this this I'm
assuming I don't know the exact date it
would it would seem likely this is on
the campaign Trail in 2019 2020 prior to
the election we know that people say a
lot of nonsense and say a lot of things
so
you know I I wouldn't look too much into
that what I'll say is this I I think it
was an ugly situation with Trump and the
double impeachment obviously he wasn't
impede or fully convicted or didn't uh
wasn't held accountable for that I think
it's a slippery slope with this what
happened in 2018 was there was sort of a
blue wave after 2016. Democrats took
over the house the Democrats took over
the Senate they had all the control
so from a logistical standpoint if how
Congress works right now 2020 they were
supposed to be I'm sorry 2022 there was
supposed to be a red wave it was a red
teardrop the Dems control the Senate
they have a small margin in the house
and if the house even brings this up
there's no way the Senate actually
passes this I don't see it happen I
think we're just it's an ugly situation
in this country where we're just like
impeach Trump and Peach Biden politics
is ugly democracy is ugly but it's the
best thing we got
who's an investigate Pat but but the
question here's the question though
here's the question though the standards
held on what they did to Trump based on
those standards the American people are
saying what what is it with you now
saying we got to move on we we had it
with Anthony Weiner we got to move on
right you know conversation with you
know uh even Chris being here with what
happened two and a half years ago it's a
lot of people that are like hey we got
to move on that's in the past we got to
look at the Future No you you humiliated
the person that voted for Trump that
person was humiliated in front of their
peers but the person that voted for
Biden looked like they knew what they
were doing and now that person that
voted for Biden is saying guys let's
just move on this is not a good thing to
do for me I don't think it's good to do
to start off with because this is not
going to stop this is going to continue
Trump's got five kids is it five or six
kids he's got five kids I think right
Ivanka Ivanka
is going to be around for 67 years which
means what that guy is going to remember
he was the kid in the white house he was
the one that has the highest intense
emotions that he watched his dad when
he's going through stuff this is not
going away anytime soon you best believe
this is going to continue in 40 years
he's going to be 56 years old and you're
going to be 80 uh years old or whatever
you're going to sit there and say look
what the sun is doing now remember when
this guy was a six eight person look
what he's up to now we don't know what
these things are going to happen but
when you play this game
and all you think about this is the
problem America has right now Medicare
Advantage Medicare and uh uh um Medicaid
Medicaid forget about it let gen Z
Millennials Gen X pay for it right let
them pay for it real estate economic
expansion don't worry about it print
some more money okay don't even worry
about it let the Next Generation pay for
it next impeachment who cares let's get
in this guy well let's we got to show
the world because let the Next
Generation and this is going to keep
continuing year after year after year
after year after so I got a question for
you guys it has nothing to do with
politics it has nothing to do with
politics I'm curious to know what you're
going to say about this then I got a
clip I want to show you guys which is
kind of weird how a lady is given a
speech and the writer in the back is
saying verbatim every word that she
wrote the speech and it's correct in
them we'll look at that here in a minute
but forget about that I'll send you the
clip here's a question I got for you Tom
which burden is a bigger burden for
example
kids are a big burden on the parents
right when you have kids it's a lot of
work you don't sleep there's a reason
why this panel out of four of us two of
us have kids two of us don't and we're
all over 40 years old okay there's a lot
of responsibility with having kids it's
a lot of work okay and it's constant
last night we're dealing with plumbing
kids got to take a shower you got to put
them to sleep you got to get up early
what's going it's just a lot of work
when you have kids
what what burden is more painful the
Burton parents put on their kids for
having not made proper decisions in life
to get the kids off to a good start
or is the bigger burden the kid that is
so responsible that is always
embarrassing the parents drugs Financial
issues constantly being in trouble not
making the right decision which is a
bigger burden parent to kids or kids to
parents Tom
you know what question I'm asking yep
well as a parent I think it's kid to
parent because you feel embarrassed you
feel ashamed you feel responsible you
were supposed to raise this kid and turn
him her it or they into a uh responsible
citizen yeah and I that would just to
see my kid failing I feel pain for their
pain and then I feel embarrassment and
then I feel responsible and then I feel
you know what could I have done
different here I think that's a bigger
burden
then the burden that maybe a parent puts
on a kid to perform even though we've
seen suicides in kids from parents that
made Straight A's an absolute let me
maybe let me ask a question in different
ways so for example Tom so you know our
job is to take care of the elderly got
it so you know I'm taking care of my dad
you're taking care of your you know your
your mom we're supposed to take a you
know whatever this person need mom needs
that person needs we got to take care of
okay fine
how much of that were the burden of the
prior generation being passed down to
the next generation is okay
what is the responsibility of Our
Generation to the Next Generation
kind of economic economically is it is
it okay to just kick the can and say
listen guys you guys are young one day
you're gonna have to take care of this
you pay the price for this your
Grandma's old your dad is old it's on
you you can handle this you're only 28
you're only 35. I'm 69. at what point is
that burden and unfair burden the prior
generation is passing down to the uh to
you know the whole thing about weak men
create Hard Times Hard Times create so
maybe a generation made weak choices and
the next generation is paying the price
for it how much of that is okay for a
generation to pass down so much burden
on the Next Generation I I
different kind of question I think what
we're doing to the next generation is
unconscionable and I think what they're
carrying is they have to figure out how
to make it in the most expensive you
know Economic Times of all time number
one and number two now they're going to
be told the only way to take care of all
these Boomers and doesn't the last
Boomer retire on Thanksgiving this year
I think it I think it is between
Thanksgiving the end of year the last
Boomer retires or hits that first
retirement age milestone
and now it's like Hey listen all the
Boomers yeah the trust fund's going to
be out the Medicare and Social Security
trust fund you can look up you can find
that chart Rob uh it's going to be gone
and so we're just going to keep you know
that little dial that says six and a
half I mean seven percent I mean seven
and a half percent Social Security we're
just going to keep turning that dial
because there's two trust funds that are
that are in there I think it's the uh
medical trust fund that they're related
to Medicare and Social Security and both
of those trust funds those charts out
there that say they are dead in
um roughly 11 years 11 years they go the
trust funds that are in there go to zero
and when they go to zero the only choice
is to hyper tax those who are working
and that is an unconscionable burden on
the Next Generation okay so here's
here's a by the way the the last Boomer
turned 65 in 2031 so we still got a few
more years left the last 46 to 64. so if
you look at 64 36 23 the the oldest
Boomer right now is 59 years old or
something like they got six more years
the youngest Boomers like 57 years old
so 1946 to 1964 I'm just doing basic
math so 57 they got nine more years uh
uh eight more years I've been reading
reading about the 59 and a half rule I'm
sorry yeah 59 and a half is going to be
probably in two years but the old
youngest Boomer turned 65 in 20 30
months regardless of 76 million of them
and it's a lot of money so here's a
here's a part about that that uh for me
uh it's deeply concerning and no one
wants to have this conversation we can
have this conversation because we're not
looking for your vote we don't need your
vote we're not running for nothing we
don't need Congress we don't need your
money we're not running for governor
we're not running for president we're
just having conversations okay as a
sales organization I run the best way to
describe this time I think you'll
understand this so in our business and
insurance when you're around for a long
time and you build a big agency what
ends up happening to you is you start
making millions of dollars but you don't
work anymore
okay not the guy that starts the company
because you're always working because
you every lawsuit everything comes to
you right but if you build an agency
within a company it could be New York
Life it could be Transamerica it could
be Primerica PHP you can go on so many
different companies if you build a big
block of business with a lot of
insurance agents you can all of a sudden
one day wake up saying hey babe we're
making two million a year and we're just
the least I've worked in the last 20
years okay
so then that generation is
famous for sometimes not wanting to do
the work taking the money and wanting to
change the compensation structure to
benefit them
because what ends up happening is the
longer you're in the business you're
override and commissions on insurance
the renewals kind of goes away because
you're no longer building new offices so
the override's going away from me so all
of a sudden you catch yourself going to
two hundred thousand dollars a month in
income 220 then it goes to 180 160 140
and then you level off like at a hundred
thousand dollars because you're no
longer growing your book of business
very interesting very simple this
happens quite often the people at the
top the elderly the people that are no
longer working start saying we need to
change the compensation plan to pay us
more this is not fair
and they take comp away from newest
agents who are just starting their
practice I don't know if I'm making
sense so the small business owners that
are starting their practice they are now
getting less of a comp than the person
that has been around for 20 30 years if
you can go to Twitter Rob yesterday I
responded to uh to the uh uh what do you
call it the incredible Hillary Clinton
no no she did not respond but you got to
go to this tweet here zoom in zoom in
right there okay and go to her tweet her
tweet says as of today it's been 14
years since 7 25 minimum wage was last
raised president of the United States
Biden supports raising the wage to at
least 15 Mega Republicans have
repeatedly blocked an increase what do
you have against millions of Working
Families making more my response what do
you have against small business owners
Fortune 500 companies would love to see
minimum wage increase they can afford it
it's the small business owners who risk
their life savings that can't you're
indirectly helping eliminate competition
for the big guys right okay so there is
no response what are you going to say to
that so okay guess what Walmart loves
the fact you raise minimum wage Joey's
Market that's been there for 73 years
past on three generations now is out of
business you're like dude that was
fantastic thank you Biden thank you
Hillary thank you Bernie you eliminated
this guy that was a pain in Diaz because
my market in this area just went up 13
because I was losing it to the other guy
okay
so indirectly if we don't talk about
this the older generation I believe
you can come at me all you want I don't
need your vote I'm simply sparking a
conversation I believe the older
generation
is be an unfair and bullying the younger
generation and not thinking about what
they're going to be have to having to do
10 20 30 years from now because they're
going to be dead and that's absolutely
unfair it is a burden that some of these
guys cannot handle and these politicians
guess what they say this is the line you
ready here's what the media will ask a
politician that's running for office
what you say right now that you have no
plans of changing any benefits to Social
Security Medicare Medicaid can you say
it right now to everybody that's
watching this I have no plans of yeah of
course what you're saying is I have no
plans of taking care of the Next
Generation that's going to suffer the
consequence of your burden that they're
probably never going to have social
security benefits Medicare Medicaid so
to me I think when you think about
parents what responsibilities do we have
to the Next Generation what what
responsibilities what do you think we a
good parent what does a good parent owe
their kids what do they owe their kids
as great parents what are we all our
kids well we are we are them structure
discipline true love not enabling love
but true love as I love you so much so
I'm going to put boundaries around you
to prevent you from making mistakes it's
not that I love you so much I'm going to
bribe you with ice cream to get you to
cooperate so it's true love boundaries
respect discipline you put that in a
package that's what you owe you let me
ask this question is there a tradition
where your parents oh
uh for the longest time would help you
with the first you know 20 down payment
on your house or a way to get you
started to say hey son you're just
getting started you're 28 years old
you're about to get married you're
starting your career you're about to buy
a million dollar house guess what I'm
going to help you with the down payment
of the house to get you guys going okay
that's what I'm going to be doing do you
think do you think that ought to be a
part of the responsibility of parents to
get their kids started in a climate like
this absolutely not tell me why I mean
if you're rich you know that that's a
conversation you could have
um some people elect to maybe say
I have
friends who are well off and they'll say
well we'll pay for your wedding
or we'll give you a down payment on your
house I don't know a lot of people whose
parents are just like yeah a couple
hundred grand got you I don't think
that's a thing
okay 50 Grand whatever the numbers I
don't know do you know a ton of people
ton of families that do that for their
kids I think in the Middle Eastern side
of course that's a big part of the
Middle Eastern culture maybe I gotta
start hanging out with Middle Easterns
but let me ask you a question in your in
America I'm actually sincerely asking
this question uh if you're if you have a
son or daughter who pays for the wedding
in America the family of the daughter or
the family of the son typically the
bride's parents it's a uh it's a
long-standing joke show up
shut up
pay up and that's the joke they always
make about the bride's father is that
tradition still going on today for the
most part yeah I mean would you say it
is yeah it is you're saying it is
let's keep that tradition going guys
let's not stop that in my show Thomas
Kelly Thomas Thomas friends lobbying for
the other way around my circle of
friends I've got two daughters it's
still happening this way okay got it so
that means you're gonna be 50 50 on this
thing yeah I'm still going to pay for
your boys I I will gladly want to give
this way and this way yeah I want to
gladly be a flag carrier to do this one
because without them I'm not around and
without them I'm not around but I think
there's too much of Burden coming down
from here in this generation I don't
think this I don't think right now a 22
year old 25 year old graduates
in a better climate than they were in
like we're having a comment Peter was
asking a question last week what was the
question you were asking you're like Pat
how is Brandon going to buy a house he
says and I've done well for myself how
are these people going to buy a house I
don't understand how people are coming
out of their careers how are you going
to buy a house the thought of buying a
house today in your 20s and your regular
person not your a peak performer you're
the top guy sales now if I'm a regular
person how does a how does a regular 28
year old person that got out of college
they got a job starting at 50 Grand a
year then they go to you get three
percent rates let's say you get four
percent raise every year okay four
percent you go from 50 to what 52 54 56
58 60 63 66 60 what 69 73 10 years 70
it's 15 years before you're at 75 after
taxes you're only making four grand a
month the mortgage payments three grand
a month so if we go the way we're going
right now the average guy coming out of
college making 50 at 22 23 24 25 you
ain't making 100 until you're 40. so if
you ain't making 100 until you're 40
you're paying 30 in taxes that's 70 000
a year that's six thousand how the hell
are you going to buy a house a 600 000
house first of all you need 20 down
payment six twenty percent on 600 000
houses 120 what do you find 120 000
you've been paying taxes every year you
need someone to help you out so to me I
think the messaging's got to be from
parents is one what value are you
passing down okay
what burden are you going to be lifting
off your kids okay is is it like if I'm
sitting here as a parent thinking and if
I have to decide between um let's just
say I'm a regular person I don't have
the the the the money that I have right
now say I'm making 92 Grand a year I'm
having a conversation with my kid and
saying hey tick Billy question for you
would you rather have me pay for your
college or would you rather have me give
you fifty thousand dollars at 25 when
you start your career or you get married
and I help you out with XYZ when
Jennifer and I were getting married I
had money in the bank I asked Jennifer
the following question I said babe
do you want a house do you want a big
wedding or do you want a big rink I'm
not doing all three
she's and by the way for us and nobody
paying for the wedding dog not from
neither side because neither our
families have money yeah okay yep one's
from Arkansas and you know Laporte Texas
and the other ones a cashier at a 99
Cent Store my dad brought a 99 cent
Clippers hat from 1990s to say hey
here's a gift but they gave us love
that's what we got we got nothing else
so I'm sitting there saying which one do
you want and she says babe I don't care
you know I have money you know how much
I paid for Jen's rink when we got
married three thousand dollars I'll give
you the exact number 3 300 she wears it
till today okay until today
we kept the cash
we rented and I said I'm not buying a
house because we're going to put this
money into our business and we had a big
wedding in our wedding 450 people it was
great we had a great time fantastic it
was good to go but I think those types
of conversations need to be had more
today to say hey kid I can pay for your
college or you can figure out a way
to get through the next phase and then
at when you get married I got 25 000 for
you and when you decide to buy a house
at 25 years old once you show me you can
make 80 grand a year or 100 Grand year
or 60 Grand year I got fifty thousand
dollars down payment a gift to your
house I think I think parents have to
also realize we have some kind of a
responsibility for them because the
burden is a big burden right now on kids
massive burnout kids right now I don't
know if this is a comfortable
conversation anybody wants to talk about
because
the burden will be on a lot of Boomers
who are sitting there saying no they
need to take care of us
[Music]
man you know it's I don't care if it's
comfortable or not I think it's a very
necessary conversation yeah I've I've
told I've told my kids and I know I
think Bailey the golf girl is probably
listening right now because it's summer
and Chin the biz doc babe tune into the
podcast hi Bailey but hello she says
hello hello
um
and what I told her I said look you will
come out
with no debt I will make sure through
your college education is no debt but
every penny you get of scholarship
whether it's athletic scholarship
academic scholarship every penny that
you can offset through your attainment
is is yours and I'm gonna we're gonna
talk about how we use that when you
graduate you want to use it starting out
fine you know weddings are a different
thing but Pat I've told them I've said
look this is what I'm going to do this
can help you start if you're if you're
starting a business whatever you're
doing but I'm not I'm not infinite here
I'm not I'm not an infinite piggy bank
this is what we have for college if you
contribute with good academic
performance and stuff then some of that
you're saving for yourself and that's a
contract that I've made made with her
and she gets it well let me just say
this your daughter's very lucky to have
a father like you because you've done
very well for yourself you love your
kids a lot you're an ideal father you're
amazing MO those kids don't have that
type of parent in their life meaning
they might have the love they might have
the structure they might have the values
they might have the principles but their
parents aren't in the top one percent
top ten percent so they got to figure it
out else elsewhere I love the example
you gave of the 25 year old who's making
50 Grand that he's making 52 then he's
making 55. there used to be a Time in
America a generation ago where a working
man can have one job the wife could stay
home with the kids he didn't need to
work and he could have paid for the
family the mortgage the car the dog the
fence the boom to everything those days
are long gone so women work these days
now it's a lot of times it takes two
incomes to raise a family you know a lot
of times they they joke and they say
that the richest people in the world are
dinks dual income no kids and because
kids are expensive I think they cost
about a quarter million bucks a year
from zero to 18. and um It's a situation
these days and and women are making more
money than ever and they're looking at
average men and they're like why do I
need you I make more than you that's why
they're all going after the top 10
percent of men and those are whole
dating situation going on these days
according to the Department of
Agriculture I don't know why they're
doing this they close 233 thousand
dollars to raise a kid from zero
eighteen unless the kids worked on a
farm that figure is likely closer to 288
but another point you talked about the
the burden you know the Baby Boomers
have sort of done the Millennials and
the Gen Z's dirty right they've run up
the debt they haven't saved a ton of
money you hear Bernie Sanders constantly
complaining you know fifty percent of
all boomers are gonna retire with no
and money but as Vinnie's
favorite word constituents that's who's
voting so the the politic politicians
are always going to Pander to the old
people because they're going to come out
and vote and they're going to vote on
the key issues which are entitlement
programs Social Security Medicare
Medicaid those aren't going away anytime
soon and it's them
the politicians are also 70 years old
exactly so you're looking in a mirror
over here but let me let me see the same
cohort let me tell you what I can't
stand when parents do to their kids I
just got to tell you and I've been
around I was trying to study my my 20s
about parenting and I'm like yeah my dad
didn't do that my dad never said make
money so he can take care of me he's
never once said that matter of fact I
had to force my dad to move to my house
he never wanted to come be a burden on
me ever he never wanted to be a burden
on me ever like it was hard for him to
already move here now don't get me wrong
he settled now he's doing great he's
happy but he's still working until today
but I think
when I see parents do stuff like this
well you know Joey here is going to grow
up to be a professional major league
baseball player so Daddy doesn't have to
work anymore you don't want to turn off
it is when I hear a father say something
like that you know what a turn off it is
what I'm watching a De La Hoya a
documentary that's talking about my dad
told me hey Miho you got to go be a
boxer so we don't have to work anymore
we can stop being poor hey
why don't you do that why didn't you do
that like why would like sales leaders
I'll see them talking to their sales
guys and they'll say stuff like this hey
uh uh you know you need to go around
appointments at 10 o'clock at night and
and what are you doing at five o'clock
you're at the house watching the Lakers
play you need to run appointments at 10
o'clock at night you're telling your
sales guys to go how come you're not
running an appointment so you can get
the override it's this concept of people
asking others to do the work that they
themselves didn't want to do why not set
the example for your kids why not set
the example of you improving yourself in
your 50s in your 60s there are parents
right now that are 60 years old they're
thinking they're dead bro Tony Bennett
died at 96 you got 35 more years of
living to do and you're only 60 years
old this concept of you know my body
hurts I'm in pain I'm in this I mean
that totally getting my dad if you look
at his hands okay if you're around my
dad his stomach he you know what do you
call it uh uh um
when the intestines he's got a hole in
it no his intestines comes out all the
way out here he has to wear a belt to
push it in okay it's a abdominal hernia
abdominal hernia hernia is what he's got
he walks like a uh uh Hunchback of uh
Iran okay yeah Dylan Dylan makes fun of
him every time he walks Dylan does the
walk he said Daddy this is how Papa
walks and he does his walk and they're
so funny
his hands arthritis okay the guy was in
a hospital a couple months ago never
once has to use that as an excuse to not
work and improve himself do you know how
much relatives of my dad my mom said I
couldn't stand him because he kept
working and relatives that we had in our
family since 40 years old have been
bitching about not being healthy and
they were 10 times healthier than my dad
and my dad had 13 heart attacks this is
not a comfortable conversation to have I
totally get it like I'm not going to
make any new friends today I'm not going
to be like I'm going to walk in Palm
Beach a 72 year old lady is going to
come and say hey how are you you're an
you know that I can't believe
you want me to work no I think the
burden is being passed out
so can we save this thing in one year no
this is something that can be fixed in
20 years this is not a one-year fix but
we can't sit there and say let's keep
passing down all this stuff to the Next
Generation screw them they got to figure
out they're younger I don't think it's
fair by the way American confidence and
higher education down sharply this is a
Gallup poll okay down sharply
uh uh here we go uh Cuomo we're having a
conversation with Cuomo in the back in a
cigar lounge and he's not sure if he's
going to put one of his kids through
college he says I'm going to have the
kid maybe go one year to see what's
going to happen with him that's a very
normal conversation people are having
right now here you go Americans
confidence and higher education has
sharply declined to 36 down from 57 in
2015. okay we're not talking about like
a slight decline in 2015 just eight
years ago we were at 57 we're at 36
percent and when there's a 48 in 2018
only 17 percent have a great deal of
confidence with 19 having a quite a lot
of confidence while 40 have some 22
percent have very little confidence all
major group subgroups particularly
Republicans have shown a decrease in
confidence Republicans experience the
largest drop falling 20 points to 19 the
lowest among group confidence amongst
adults without a college degree and
those age 55 and older are also dropped
significantly so watch watched it
Republican confidence major drop off
confidence amongst adults without a
college degree major drop off which
makes sense they didn't have one either
but the one that's confusing is aged 55
and older your 55 those are the people
that tell their grandkids to do what go
to school stay in college get a degree
now they're saying hey Johnny guess what
I changed my mind yeah you may have
other options Democrats are the only
subgroup with majority level confidence
and higher education at 59 there's a
growing divide between Republicans and
Democrats regarding their confidence
with Democrats concerned about costs and
Republicans expressing concerns about
politics and higher education so guess
what families are not even waking up
right now saying hey let's send our kids
to school there's other ways to make
money today so Tom for somebody that
went to school you were a Adjunct
professor at Biola at Pepperdine what do
you see when you're seeing something
like this and your daughter just three
weeks ago got 1560 on her SATs so I see
you two things going on right now
um obviously the the circle my Social
Circle is a lot of conservative people
that are concerned about they said they
call it here politics it's quality Dems
are concerned about price Republicans
concerned about quality it's kind of
interesting it's a very economic
balancer but in in my Social Circle I'm
seeing people very concerned about this
and very concerned about sending their
kid for school for anything except stem
or business or technical skill meaning
medicine like you're going to be an
engineer that's stem medicine that's
also STEM Science technology engineering
math correct or they're going to get a
business degree because they can apply
that if you want to run a non-profit go
get a management degree you can apply
that so people are concerned about
anything but that because of
indoctrination and quality on that side
on the other side you know people are
concerned about the ongoing cost that's
why Dems want you know forgive all the
students loans I bought and paid for
something I don't like it anymore and
now I want to get a refund is basically
what it boils down to what I see is I
see you know
a problem with education itself that has
run amok and one of you're talking about
changes in government one of the things
that I would go after is I would go
after the the enablement of student
loans because if student loans get
forgiven
what did the university is going to do
drop their prices no they're sitting on
these giant endowments they're not going
to drop the price because the next the
next generation is going to get student
loans again they can charge whatever
price they want and the federal
government is a backstop of
affordability so all these kids can just
get the student loans and and run the
tab up again it is a vicious credit card
cycle I think the problem is two-sided
it's the cost the opportunistic
non-profit universities that keep
raising the cost and what they've
decided to be woke in teaching that's
the problem that is the whole problem
and on the other side of it you've got
rational people are saying man if my
kid's not going to go into stem or
business I'm really worried about this
because what are you going to do with
that education you know you know what
it's like last night it's midnight this
guy plumber comes up and his name is
Vinnie okay Santa couldn't believe it
really issued yeah so we're outside
flashlight all this stuff here's the
issue there's flooding everywhere it's a
mess
and in my mind while I'm walking up he
says I'm about to give you the quote on
what it's going to cost you to fix this
you know what I'm saying in my mind
okay so let's just say he says a
thousand dollars
which wasn't a thousand dollars a lot
more than a thousand dollars
what am I going to say yeah let me get a
second uh opinion at midnight yeah no
and not have waterfalls he also sees
your house you also see the house he
sees the community so that I'm like
in my mind I'm asking what's your number
that you're going to say no to yeah then
you know what one side of PVD said
there is no number
I'm not joking with you there is no
number what am I gonna do yeah say no
the the heater is about to explode the
tank because dirt is going through it so
if you leave it like that it's going to
go into all then then it's going to be a
forget it half a million dollar a
million dollar deal because it's all
this stuff that within the house
so he gives me the number
and what are you negotiating
there is no negotiation I believe no
okay no problem you want to think about
it yeah oh cool okay yeah the problem's
gonna get bigger but you literally have
no power in this position the only thing
that that person has to think about is
do I want this guy as a referral source
or do I want this guy to keep doing
business with me so he can rip me off
once and I'll never do business with
them and I still have to pay him and
I'll tell the world about it or he can
be fair and I'll continue doing business
with him and I'll tell the world about
it guess what he tells me the price I
said why is this going to cost us much
money because this part is this much
money I go online he was right in front
of him I'm doing it the part was fifteen
hundred dollars then there's labor then
him coming up at late then he's dug the
whole thing the whole guy's dirt yeah
dirty all over the place on him right so
I said no problem let's go ahead and do
we cut the check
you know a few thousand dollars right
there whatever
but
what's the moral of the story guess what
the same way hospitals are not regulated
on what they charge you when you stay at
that there is no rate you know hospitals
don't have a regulation what they can
charge you do you know that they can
charge you there is no menu when you go
to the hospital saying how much does
this cost how much does that cost
the same way hospitals don't have a menu
with prices because they can choose
whatever they want the prices to be
colleges don't have a regulation of what
the price are going to be colleges can
increase it and say don't no problem
don't do whatever you want there is no
regulation the only thing we ever did to
hold hospitals accountable was in
2019-2020 Trump came out with a Law to
force hospitals to put their numbers
publicly or else they're going to get
fined Guess what at a 6 000 hospitals
Brandon how many of them have been fined
four out of 6 000 hospitals have been
fined four out of six thousand hospitals
have been fined they're like screw you
we're not going to put these numbers
publicly only four have been fined and
the fine is like 20 grand it's not it's
not like a big fine that they're doing
anyways they wanted to raise it to 2
million for bigger hospitals more of the
story here right now
there has to be a major shift in the way
the economy is going
people's income hasn't exploded the sole
concept of the rich getting richer poor
getting poor middle class the middle
class is gone RFK talked about this
recently when he was talking to Debbie
Wasserman if he can pull up this story
Rob to go transition into that he said
that's the only thing that sustains
democracy Pat is a middle class and
that's what they've been trying to get
rid of is the middle class because if
you just have rich and poor it's it's
not let me let me let me read this so
rfk's RFK Jr snaps at Debbie Wasserman
Schultz you are slandering me this is a
story that just came up this was what a
couple days ago yeah last week if you
have the clip on Twitter Rob to show it
uh uh uh let me see here page seven so
RFK sparred with Florida uh rep by the
way yeah Florida represents Debbie
Wasserman Schultz over his history of
controversial statements on Thursday
testifying before so-called house
subcommittee on the weaponization of the
federal government Kennedy denied the
congressman's congresswoman's
characterization of his commit comments
that covid-19 may have been ethnically
targeted a acting Jewish and Chinese
people less than others as washer
Wasserman Schultz attempted to cut him
off Kennedy got frustrated you are
slandering me incorrectly what you're
saying is dishonest angrily angrily
pointed a finger in her Direction asked
about another one of his past statements
in which he invoked Nazi Germany while
discussing covid-19 Public Health
restrictions he again barked back
Congressman what you're saying is simply
a lie can you pull up this video real
quick how long is this video Rob uh two
minutes 39 seconds go ahead we'll play
we'll play part of it go for it Mr
Superior here due to his repeated and
very recent statements that spread
dangerous anti-semitic and anti-asian
conspiracy theories and attempted to
move into executive session because
house rules prohibit public testimony
that degrades or defames people his
Reckless rhetoric helped fuel
anti-semitic incidents which for the
record are at the highest level in the
United States since 1970 they have
nearly tripled in the last six years
since you gave Mr Kennedy a megaphone
today I want to give him a chance to
correct his statements and prepare some
of the harm that he's helped cause
Mr Kennedy you're well educated
yes or no please are you aware that for
centuries Jews have been scapegoated and
blamed for causing illnesses like black
plague and more recently covet
and those are known as blood libel and
they are one of the worst the most
disturbing parts of uh human history
good I'm glad to know that of course
that you that you acknowledge that of
course it's true and well documented
that his permission to finish his form
of anti-Semitism led to centuries of
discrimination even horrific programs
and massacres and it still fuels deadly
violence today yet last week you floated
a baseless conspiracy theory that the
coronavirus was bioengineered to Target
Caucasians and black people but to spare
Ashkenazi Jews and Chinese people Mr
Kennedy you're a bizarre unproven claim
Echoes that same historic slander of
labeling Jews and Chinese people as a
race and that Jews and in this case
Chinese people somehow managed to avoid
a deadly illness that targets other
groups for death you do see that yes or
no you're mistating no no no no I quoted
what you said earlier and it is directly
what you said so just ask
I was describing
and NIH funded studies no no you didn't
say I was describing an NIH funded study
by Cleveland clinics
reclaiming my time
reclaiming published in USC medical
which is the time is mine I'm reclaiming
it please ask the witness to stop
talking you asked me a question reclaim
it let me allow me to answer my question
Mr chairman I'd like about 10 seconds
I'd like 15 seconds back we will be
happy to give you that thank you so much
we will be happy you did not cite any
study like you are citing here now
during that conversation you reference
no study at all you simply labeled Jews
and Chinese people as a race and you
also said that somehow they managed to
avoid a deadly illness that targets
other groups for death you don't see
that you're trying to rewrite history
here
okay so reaction to it right you're
seeing what's going on go ahead she well
first of all let's just I don't want
everybody to forget who Debbie Wasserman
Schultz is she know who she is right
that you know during the 2016 election
first of all I want to make one point
look at look at what happens when you
work with the cleanse this is Debbie
Wasserman Schultz 2016 and once you
start working with the Clinton something
happens then show our photo right now
look at that is what happens to you when
you're in with the clients and Patrick
she was she was doing it it's not the
same person that's her that is her
that's the Clinton juice inside you
right there so listen she was a DNC
obviously didn't drink that uh
looks like a drowning you guys know what
happened she was the DNC chair and then
Wikileaks released a bunch of emails
between her and the heads of the DNC
trying to oust uh Bernie Sanders so
that's when you're evil inside that's
what comes out of you but Pat let's not
let's not forget this is what happens
when when you're uh uh you're trying to
run for the Democratic party and you
said stuff like verbatim Democrat
parties become a party of forever Wars
the party of pharmaceuticals and the
party of censorship okay he's he's doing
exactly he want his father and his uncle
uh tried to do and that's helped the
American people but when they want to
knock you down what do they go what do
they go to what's their playbook you're
racist that's number one and mind you
this is a censorship meeting and they're
a hearing and they're trying to censor a
guy and everything that she said was
completely false and uh think about this
the fact that they can't assassinate
them Pat because you know what everybody
has a camera it's not just a Pruder with
one camera on the grass you know
everybody has a camera if they could
kill him they would but they cancel when
they can't assassinate you with a gun
they assassinate your character I saw
those videos he didn't say any of that
in that contest this is supposed to be a
hearing a hearing is supposed to be a
two-way
exchange where Congress subpoenas you
and experts presented by the government
and people that are there like the
social media people are there are we
really having teen suicides here and
they bring everybody together and they
debate it she is sitting there and
trying to Corner okay I'm going to talk
for 60 seconds yes or no please yes or
no please and just like I can't answer
that yes or no I can't answer that yes
or no you're asking me a question it it
invokes dialogue and this is Debbie do
it to each other to be fair both sides
do it to each other Republicans do to
them stems due to Republicans but that's
not the that's not the concern the
concern to me is how much they they fear
him big time okay how much they fear and
by the way that's why here here's the
part we have to realize
unfortunately
unfortunately he can't be the Ross Pro I
keep talking about that you know he
could be the Ross Pearl I don't think he
can go back and run as a third party if
it doesn't work out for me he's done
done he's ran as a Democrat he can't run
as a third party by the at the end he's
going to make a lot of noise he's going
to do what he's doing and eventually
he'll be out and they're not even
worried about RFK they're not even
sitting and worried about him but they
fear Him they can't stand him he's in
the way in the same exact way by the way
look at the profile of the establishment
who they like and who they don't like
you want to know who the establishment
likes here's who the establishment likes
the established establishment loves and
this is where Chris and I disagree
because everything he said to me I'm
like you sound like an
anti-establishment guy what happened to
you in the last two and a half years
we've had a lot of good conversations
the last couple days uh but you know the
anti-establishment this is what they
don't like they don't like somebody they
cannot control okay they like people
they can't control they didn't they
couldn't control Andrew Cuomo and of
course he had some uh issues in the past
but you've known that for many years so
the DNC just waited until they knew they
couldn't control him I bet there was a
call again this is speculation I bet
there was a call saying Andrew if you
don't do XYZ the way we want it here's
what's going to be happening and guess
what what do you think Andrew probably
said no boom you're out you're fired
immediately is fired hey guess what RFK
here's what we know about you if you
don't come out and follow order guess
what you're going to be fired he's not
doing it you think this is the worst of
what they're going to do to them oh no
this is just the beginning what they're
going to do to this guy the best stuff
they're hanging out to is the next
couple months here what's going to
happen to him but the whole conversation
here started with the fact that the way
America is going today
the way America is going today the
future is going to be not necessarily
that bright for the Next Generation
because the future is going to be filled
with burdens for the Next Generation if
we don't make better decisions Today
college education is being challenged
beautiful thing our current system
economically is being challenged
beautiful thing our term limits is being
challenged with Congress because they're
not making the best choices are all
they're thinking about is what can get
them re-elected beautiful thing there's
about five or six things we can do to
put accountability onto people that they
can get fired if we don't have that it's
going to be gone one of the things I
love the difference between insurance
and and mortgage and real estate check
this out think about the level of
accountability this part sucks about
insurance but it's also great about
insurance so watch this
if I sell you a million dollar house I'm
a realtor I sell you a million dollar
house it's Tom's house Tom bought this
house 20 years ago he's got a 500 000
loan okay and he is now selling it to
Adam okay so Adam pays a million Tom
walks away with what 500
000 minus whatever he paid to the
Sellers fiamma's realtor and I walk away
selling a million dollar house at say
four percent five percent let's say five
percent fifty thousand dollars
commission if I'm at fifty percent I
just got what twenty five thousand
dollars the bank you Vinnie working for
B of A get the loan
so you gave him a loan of a million
dollars unless you say six percent today
so you're like yeah no problem I'll give
him a loan for six percent based on his
credit he walks over with a half a
million I walk over with the commission
he's not living in the house you got the
loan okay six months later if Adam says
screw this I don't want to make the
payment anymore
okay I don't want to make the payment
anymore
what do I say
can you call me and tell me hey Pat this
was your client you sold it to this no
no I got my commission you can't do
nothing to me can you the bank go after
Tom nope Tom got his money he sold his
house it's not on him the only person
right now that is left with that debt is
who you there is no charge back to me
there is no charge back to Tom and guess
what Adam's gonna say I'm not gonna make
the payments for a year and guess what
you can't kick me out because there's
laws in different states that you can't
I don't know what the names of those
laws are but you can't kick me out I'm
staying in this house okay
so in Insurance here's how it works he
is the client
your AIG I sell him a million dollar
insurance policy and it's 250 a month
you AIG pay me an advanced commission
one-year Advanced commissions let's just
say you pay me three thousand dollars
make sense if three months later Adam
says I don't want to make the payment
anymore and he says zero guess who calls
me to go collect the payment from Adam
you AIG and guess what you tell me if
you don't collect the payment from Adam
you're about to get a charge back of
three thousand dollars that money is
going to come back to us so guess what
I'm doing I'm calling Adam to make sure
we collect the money this is why many
Realtors and loan officers don't want to
go into life insurance because they love
the fact that they can sell and there is
no chargeback and this is why in my
opinion insurance agents are bigger
professionals because they have to
follow up and if you're not a
professional you're out of the industry
there's a reason why it's a great life
long term so what's the moral of the
story I just gave you a master class on
how insurance and real estate pays
Commission the more we can have
accountability of multiple parties this
has happened with Medicare and Medicaid
the health insurance company gets their
premium on a monthly basis they pay
their deductible whatever it is and they
walk when I got my money I don't have to
worry about it it's on you now Hospital
go collect that money you got to do what
you got to do the more there's
accountability to education why are you
charging this much money based on what
why are you doing this why are you
charging us so much for Medicare
Medicaid why are we not finding out
about all this cost if we can get
everybody to be publicly held
accountable for the decisions they're
making Everything Will Change what did
Warren Buffett said he said I can fix
the national debt problem in five
seconds by doing what if what's his
words Rob if he can pull this up it's
all over the place Warren Buffett how to
fix the national debt you just got to
type that into Twitter he had a whole
fact it was quick it was very just type
in Warren Buffett national debt just
type in national debt 10 seconds 10
seconds go to videos don't give what he
says let's hear what he says yourself so
right there click on that one right
there make that bigger yeah it's 42
seconds can you play that oh it's uh
okay if you can make that bigger audio
beautiful Becky perfect watch this this
is Warren Buffett 100 billion Auto guy
here's what he says go for it these
problems are are problems that have
built up over decades and there hasn't
been a congress that's been mature
enough for a president that's been
mature enough to take this head off I
can end the deficit in five minutes I
just passed a law that says that anytime
there's a deficit of more than three
percent of GDP all sitting members of
Congress are ineligible for re-election
beautiful now you've got the incentives
at the right place right okay
by the way that's accountability big
time the curse award in America the last
30 years has been accountability if we
can bring accountability in hospitals in
Congress in Medicare Medicaid in real
estate in education a lot of things are
going to change but they fear that one
word accountability they feared I want
them because you can get away with
murder if there's no accountability well
and just one side of the political
Spectrum Pat that's been preaching and
controlling people by saying you're not
accountable for that you've been
victimized and I'm here to help you
and how has that been working out yeah
terrible yeah how has that been working
for those people okay has your has your
hero of victimhood you know helped you
over the last 20 years are you better
off than you were 20 years ago no but
you keep voting for it it's crack
cocaine now and you keep voting for it
by the way so we talk about this stuff
you can say Pat you're crazy that's
insane it's not fair what about this
what about that some of you may say like
when I did the interview with Anthony
Weiner and obviously I said I would
never bring up frazzle drip because it's
irresponsible right I would never bring
that for 9 out of 12 cops that committed
a suicide within a few months that's
irresponsible and then I talk about why
are all these people dying dying and I
said your reaction is an answer to
Anthony Weiner right and media reacts to
it people write about it there's all
these other videos like guess what
happened maybe it influenced a few
people to go look into it and say why is
this happening matter of fact just this
couple days ago yesterday story comes
out about what a story comes out about
Barack Obama's Chef personal nine
one-to-one phone call for Obama's Chef
reported possibly drowning Martha's
Vineyard is plunge into chaos as body of
ex-presidents cook 45 years old is found
100 feet from Shore in paddle boarding
drowning accident let me read the story
to you
and we're not tying the two together by
the way this is just the story of people
to do research so it says tafari
Campbell Great Name a former uh Chef for
the Obamas was found dead in eight feet
of water after a possible drowning
incident while paddle boarding on Edgar
Town Great Pond Massachusetts witness
Witnesses saw him struggling to stay
afloat before he went underwater around
7 46 p.m Massachusetts State Police U.S
Coast Guard and local authorities
including Edgartown fire an air Wing
were part of the rescue mission Michelle
and Barack Obama paid tribute to
Campbell stating tafari was a beloved
part of our family a warm fun
extraordinary kind of person who made
all of our lives a little brighter
Campbell was known for Brewing White
House honey Ale Beer and was one of the
four white house cooks asked to stay
under the Obama Administration when the
story first broke a lot of different
media Outlets said the fact that he
didn't know how to swim matter of fact
there was a post of Instagram
of him hashtag still don't know how to
swim or something like that I don't know
if you saw that or not where he didn't
know how to swim and then a video
appeared Rob I don't know if you have
the video or not there's a video on him
I've been swimming right there this is
him this is him on Twitter uh if you can
play this clip he knows how to swim Pat
he's so this is him swimming that's
pretty solid to swim like that that's
backstroke that he's doing there is
Clippers on he says progress fit chef
and uh well there's one way he's doing
the backstroke he's doing the butterfly
yeah so this is him I don't know if I
would call him an Olympic swimmer but I
think he knows how to swim okay and if
you're an eight feet of water and you
don't know how to swim all you got to do
look he's doing the backstroke so look
the story first said he didn't know how
to swim then this came out that he knew
how to swim uh by the way he had twin
Sons with his wife he had twin Sons with
his wife and the story is out while
we're watching this Opera my chef is
standing next to me saying Albert did
you see the story he's kind of like you
know I was saying earlier he ran out I
haven't seen him since he just took off
did you see did you see well first of
all paddle boarding there's no there's
no weight there's no waves there's no
nothing it was late at night he was with
somebody else he was with another male
which nobody knows what happened to that
to that guy and then Hillary Clinton I
guess had the same not not a swimming
incident but didn't one of her chefs
pass away this guy he died by drowning
in 2015 it's just a weird it's just
weird coincidences that these people are
just randomly drowning and dying mind
you it's Pat if you're not home as your
Chef is your personal chef chilling at
your house and swimming and is Albert
hanging out your house when you're not
there what what I'm not there no no but
but I don't think that's a that would be
the reason to jump into conclusion that
something could be happening the whole
point is when when something like this
happened you like for example I went and
ate at this one restaurant MC Chef I
don't know what it's called it's a
beautiful place in Miami
and Sam and I are there and I said so
tell me the history about this
restaurant I asked the waiter and the
waiter says oh you don't know the story
this restaurant now he says the chef
used to cook for the Miami Heat all the
time so LeBron wait everybody would come
here all the time I said no way he says
yes he says you know what happened I
said what he says LeBron like the chef
so much that he hired him and they moved
to LA with them I was like oh cool nice
because this happens like for me there's
a guy right here I like to go to a
restaurant I go to I really like the way
he does things
if one day I run a restaurant or we do
anything I would like him to come with
us because I trust him there's a
relationship with a chef so Obama's
obviously trusted these guys so let's
just kind of look at it without jumping
into conclusion with anything they like
the chef so much they said hey why don't
you come and be a chef for us so take
all the other stuff that people are
speculating something could have
happened something was natural it took
place it's tragic etc etc yeah great
they were out of town some like this
happen now the other side
is if you can play this clip this is
from June 24th of 2015. if you want to
play this I don't know how Walter sheep
died his body was found Sunday night
just off the Yerba Canyon trailhead in
very rugged terrain New Mexico State
Police say after an autopsy the medical
investigator reports she drowned and his
death is officially an accident she
moved to Taos in March a friend told our
partners to journal here for President
Bush and he previously worked as a chef
in the White House first under Bill
Clinton and stayed on when George W bush
took over last night President Clinton
released a statement reading in part
Hillary and I are saddened by the tragic
passing of former White House Executive
Chef Walter sheep our family was
grateful to have Walter with us in the
white house for six years where we and
visitors from around the world loved his
delicious and creative meals and former
first lady Laura Bush added President
Bush and I are saddened by the tragic
death the former White House Executive
Chef Walter Scheib Walter was an
outstanding Talent he prepared
magnificent dinners for world leaders in
delicious fair for our family and
friends George and I send our heartfelt
sympathy to Walter's loved ones I would
say a couple things number one moving
forward before you become a chef at the
White House you have to take a one-month
swimming lesson like that has to be
mandated because we can't afford these
sets it's a pattern so now somebody may
say come on guys I can't believe you're
going there
do you have establishment presidents you
know Chef you know drowning all those
three are pretty establishment type of
presidents a little bit weird that the
average person is saying that's kind of
weird right so why do we talk about this
kind of stuff
we're not talking about the educational
system is there a reason to send your
kids to school or not you know what it
does somebody watches it and they go
take a deeper dive and say this is my
cause the other night we're doing an
event here with Dave Smith we're in the
back having cigars with a bunch of
different guys and everybody's asking
these questions and saying so what do I
do next what is my cause what is my
fight what is my this there's about a
hundred fights you can pick and choose
okay one could be you don't like the
educational system in America be
obsessed about it go study every single
thing you can about the educational
system in different countries what's
right what's wrong what works what
doesn't become maniacal about that one
topic another one could be what's going
on with lgbtq in schools and what
they're doing go spend hundreds of hours
just studying that topic know so much
about it on how other countries handle
it and come out and say why are we doing
this this is kind of weird when did this
happen like the video we do with the
lgbtq video in schools be being exposed
the dark side of it go to your own due
diligence with it but the point is we do
this podcast
and we bring variety of guests for it to
spark like I just watch right now in the
comments section Eric Rodriguez is it
Scott Rodriguez I'm sorry Scott
Rodriguez has been a member of pbd
podcast paying on a monthly basis for 13
months now congratulations Scott we
appreciate your loyalty but he just
quietly we don't normally recognize
these guys he just bought 10 memberships
for other members to be on the pbd
podcast right now he did that shout out
to you Scott I'm sure we're going to see
here with the vedex event World War II
he's the one that gave me a sick gift
that got me emotion when I read the note
but we do this and then people go and
they can come back and send an email and
say Pat this is where you were wrong all
ears great I want to read about it tell
me expose it or Pat I didn't think you
even went that deep into it you guys
should have gone deeper or Vinnie that
one thing you talked about read this
article hey Tom can you read that
article hey Adam can you read this
article and then the stories go more and
more and more but I think it's just a
little bit weird that all of a sudden
chefs have a pattern of disappearing
from three presidents that are very
close to you
and I'm not a conspiracy theorist but
isn't it weird you tweet at Hillary
yesterday and all of a sudden your
plumbing is something's wrong with your
plumbing I'm just throwing that out
there something's wrong with his
Plumbing all of a sudden in a
multi-million dollar house all of a
sudden there's poop stuck in the pipes I
don't know Pat that's yeah suddenly you
have a sewage Fountain and reflecting
pool in front yeah I think that's
Hillary you saw what happened oh Debbie
Wasserman Schultz she looks like an
alien now you got to be careful Pat it's
perfectly acceptable for them well the
most interesting thing the whole thing
is the uh the Clinton quote about losing
their chef was actually dated a week
before he died so it's sort of
interesting maybe they were going to be
out of town they were going to be out
they're going to be out of town the
following week and had to just be sure
they you know I think it's perfectly
acceptable for the line of questioning
that used on Anthony Weiner especially
how close he was with the clintons and
all the stories in the narrative that
have been surrounding that at the same
time
let's not rush to judgment I would even
speculate on what the Obamas did or the
bush did with the chef I think it's a
little too premature I think that uh
we're it's a well within our right to to
bring it up no doubt uh do I think there
was anything nefarious do I think that
the Obamas had the chef killed because
no I'm not there you know how I feel
about that 100 but you do your thing
yeah I'll do my thing I think that it it
it does deserve attention you know and
uh if you do want to look into it more
something tells me there was nothing
nefarious going on here but we'll see
how there's a 99 chance there was
nothing he drowned but here's the part
yeah the one thing we need does that
mean the one percent chance doesn't
require a level of accountability and
due diligence and research not at all no
doubt go look it up and see what comes
out but there's a 99 chance there was
nothing nefarious going on here uh in
regards to Hillary Clinton different
story it's one too many names I think
I'm not at 99 chance I'm probably closer
to a different percentage but it is what
it is so I want to show you a clip here
why the the American people if you're
somebody that's watching this and saying
I don't know if I trust the government
as much as I used to maybe you have a
valid reason can you play this clip with
this can you play this clip oh by the
way yeah LeBron James son just uh
suffered Cardiac Arrest what Ronnie
James suffers Cardiac Arrest
just now what the hell this just
happened right now yeah Cardiac Arrest
this is his first year
you know people are going to ask because
you know what's going to happen was he
vaccinated that's gonna be the number
one question was he vaxxed because you
know LeBron is 100 I want to find out if
he's an 18 year old super athlete son of
a billionaire why is he collapsing now
this that is a story that we can discuss
and speculate that is very weird can we
scroll down is there any uh
justification because that's going to be
the question and like the same thing
with Jamie Foxx is the question is are
you backs are you boosted are you the
eldest son of Laker supercella was
hospitalized Monday after going to
Cardiac Arrest collapsing during a
basketball practice he's 18 placed in
ICU now in stable condition he was
practicing suffered Cardiac Arrest
medical staff was able to treat Ronnie
take him to the hospital media update
more information
but it says that LeBron James and his
family are vaccinated yeah there's no
listen back and I very very strange and
I'm I'm you know I'm getting sick and
tired of people that are like like just
like the Anthony Weiner's pet they're
like no you guys like man people have
been collapsing and people are there's
I've been alive for 45 years and I'm
pretty I paid attention never in the
history of my life have I seen this many
people these ages College college people
interviewers the soccer that soccer
interviewer just passed out and fainted
like no it's not like oh they're
dehydrated no something is going on and
there's no excuse you don't think he's
get seen by doctors and he has he's in
Tip-Top shape the the son of the the
dopest basketball player on the planet
that does all the money in the world an
18 year old has no business collapsing
very weird I'm sorry bro let's see so
like that just said do your research dig
into it and you said they are vaccinated
Rob yes that's according right here
God knows how many boosters who knows
well listen this has happened a couple
times I think it happened Peter with
Reggie Lewis right it happened with them
and it also happened with Pistol Pete
when it happened to him in Pasadena at a
First Nazarene Church actually I used to
go to that place in a pickup game he had
a heart attack in the middle of the
basketball game he just collapsed so
it's it's happened before yes
this is not the a first or the last time
that it happened but we're gonna see
what kind of Investigation they're going
to do into this because it shouldn't be
happening to a healthy 18 year old kid
the Marcus Aldridge a year ago had to
sit out an entire season for heart
issues who's the tall who's the boss
Chris Boss had something
no he had blood clots
something as well years ago Alonso
morning I don't know if you remember
when he had to do very weird this sucks
this is sad this is horrible to hear
um let's not rush a judgment a lot of
people rush to judgment about Jamie Foxx
recently he just came out and
basically said I'm back yeah and there
was there was some sort of I don't know
if it was a stroke situation well that's
the thing nobody knows yeah nobody has
anything right about it but it is very
weird the question what's going on it's
too early listen LeBron if there's one
thing I I don't agree with LeBron on
many things LeBron's the way his
relationship is with his kids on how he
allowed his son to change the name from
LeBron to Brony to have his own identity
he he everything about him as a father
family he does it right so Props to him
in that area and I'm sure the last thing
you want is a father going through the
pain I've seen something like this and
with your son totally agree forget about
the fact that it's embarrassing or
whatever it's public the pain of a
father and a mother going through it so
let's let's let this thing uh uh uh come
out we'll see hear more stories about it
later on so go to this clip here little
weird clip when I saw this clip so
here's somebody that's given a message
reading something and I want you to see
the girl in the back on how she's just
watching it's a little weird okay tell
me please
watch this the girl in the right corner
listen
can you raise the audio or that said Rob
wait oh she's looking yeah she looks
like she's gonna pass out please
oh she's reading it to herself yeah the
question was asked okay if someone were
to leave here today or to leave this
interview in order to suggest or imply
that when you said the laptop was real
that it meant that the FBI had
affirmatively aliens
watch that the laptop a long time argue
that the contents belong that look is
like if you're playing poker against
somebody like that off the table
answer by Ms demo they would be look how
she corrected
do you think that is though I feel like
staffers are writing speeches all the
time 100 Debbie Wasserman I don't think
that's the part that's weird I think the
the topic of this issue is very weird
they're talking about Hunter Biden and
you know for her to be sitting there
freaking out with the words that coming
out of the person that's speaking you
know it's a little bit concerning that
she has to correct the person that
doesn't know how to you know yeah that
didn't even write it Shocker the
politician is just reading words that
are on the screen like Ron Burgundy
weird weird yeah well Stay classy Adam
absolutely honestly yeah
speaking on something and somebody kept
popping up like that that wouldn't I
don't know I don't know how many leaders
that would play well be like hang on a
second don't interrupt me let me deliver
look I deliver a speech I Have to make a
statement for better for worse I have to
do it but don't make me look weak by
popping up next to me forget about the
week that this to me was a little bit a
little bit weird uh on the way she was
handling herself I may have a
conversation with her and I'm gonna say
hey can we have a conversation I want
you to watch yourself on this video why
do you look like the Unabomber like
you're tied up with all these bombs
around you relax right take it easy just
sit down and you know correct me if you
need to but wipe that look off your face
you look scary anyways Netanyahu warns
Israel is on the brink of a military
coup this is a story from the Jewish
press Israel prime minister Benjamin
yeshu is a warning about a potential
military coup stating when elements and
Military
try with threats to indicate to dictate
policy to the government this is
unacceptable in any democracy and if
they succeed in dictating
their threats this is the end of a
genuine democracy Netanyahu accuses
prime minister Ehud Barack of being The
Mastermind behind the coup attempt
funding and orchestrating protest uh
barack's 2020 video interview is incited
where he discussed methods leaders and
goals of protest movements clashes
between the government and demonstrators
have been escalating with uh reservists
and military personnel experiencing
expressing uh reluctance to comply with
the government's policies there are
concerns about possible use of force and
disruptions going on here so Adam what
is what's going on here right now with
Israel yeah well this is a story that
I've actually been following pretty
closely because I was just in Israel
I don't know three weeks ago and amazing
Place amazing country went and saw
Jerusalem Tel Aviv I went to The
Armenian quarter I saw your people I
went to the Christian quarter Tom I saw
your people I went to the alien quarter
and saw your people went to the Jewish
quarter I went to the Muslim quarter I
went and experienced it all but what I
did see specifically in Tel Aviv were a
lot of protests
um at the at the train stations and I
told my buddy who was driving around
like what's going on here they're like
Netanyahu yeah protest it's going on
he's trying to be a dictator and uh
judicial reform I'm like what is going
on here right now so I explored this a
little bit more and I've been following
the story here's what I've basically
uncovered so
um essentially there's
the best way to understand what's
happening in Israel is be the closest
analogy that I can make to Bibi
Netanyahu is it'd be it'd be like let's
say Donald Trump was President for
um multi multi-terms yes okay because
bibi's been in politics I want to say
the prime minister in and out of
politics for 20 years but basically he
was accused of all sorts of stuff he's
he's on the likud party which is the
right-wing conservative party
um and he was basically uh convict uh
accused of illegal actions and bribery
and all this kind of stuff but he came
back it's almost like as if Trump won
again in 2024 after being removed in
2020 and he's back and here's what I
will tell you just to kind of start the
start the overarchings theme Here
uh just like in America there's liberals
and conservatives and all sorts of
things it's all that and then some in
Israel so if you go to Jerusalem it's
very religious it's very conservative uh
it's Orthodox Jews if you go to Tel Aviv
bro that is LGBT Pride Central like it's
to the point where I'm like whoa relax
yeah it was clear there was more Pride
Flags in Tel Aviv than there were
Israeli Flags it was quite shocking to
me now they said well it was just Pride
week a couple weeks ago they haven't
removed all the flags but it's very very
let's just say woke yeah so what's
happening right now
is since BB Netanyahu nobody's denying
the fact that they've had amazing
economic growth in the last 20 years
nobody Israel there's a book that I read
years ago called startup Nation the
technology sector the military sector
the business sector the entrepreneurial
sector have grown exponentially uh in
the last 20 years yeah here's the book
right here came out in 2011 exactly so
nobody's denying that what they are
basically saying is that
um BB is basically becoming more of an
authoritarian regime almost like Trump's
back he made it back in office and now
he's trying to take a stronghold on the
uh on the on the country
um and let's not forget Israel is the
only democracy in the Middle East some
some countries are closed some say
Algeria some say Lebanon ish that's the
only full-on democracy that's why their
interests are aligned with the United
States there's a common interest and
shared values to be clear here what Bibi
Netanyahu is doing the following he's
basically doing a Judicial overhaul
essentially what his premise is is like
look the Supreme Court has been too
activists and too liberal for many years
it's time for us to take it over so
um what's happening is essentially the
probably the most serious domestic
crisis possibly ever in the 75-year
history of the United States we all know
that they have foreign issues with Iran
with the Palestinians with Middle
Eastern countries but this is the
probably the biggest
um
assault on Democracy the biggest issue
that they've had in 75 years now his
Coalition is basically saying we're with
you the Supreme Court has way too many
problems
um the people on the left are basically
saying this is overreach and it's
playing out I mean ultimately it comes
down to this democracy is ugly people
voted for BB Netanyahu I actually think
he's a strong leader a capable leader
but I actually completely understand the
people on the left that are basically
saying no the Supreme Court should not
be essentially shut down and quelled and
they're worried that he's becoming a
strong man and at the end of the day I
think what is it Churchill said
democracy is the worst form of
government except for everything else
we're watching how the sausage gets made
it's not pretty it's not fun to watch
but what are your Alternatives Saudi
Arabia Iran uh Libya Syria Lebanon I'll
take what's going on in Israel over any
other country in the Middle East you
know when I when I think about Netanyahu
I see somebody by the way they reached
out about wanting to do an interview so
we're right now talking to see what's
going to happen you know we don't want
to do a one-hour one I'd like to do a
two-hour one because I got a lot of
questions to ask so we may go actually
fly out there to do the interview if so
if it doesn't happen it was more of an
hour one if it does happen know the fact
that it's going to be two hours Israel
it's called we meet in the middle 50 50
an hour and a half I'm more two hours so
if they do it we'll fly for me to take
time to go out there and I by the way
respect to him he's got a tough job he's
got a lot of other responsibilities uh
but we would love to talk to them we'd
love to talk to a lot of different
people but uh you know when I see
Netanyahu I see someone that wants this
job like I see someone that's been
wanting this job for a very very long
time and he was upset that he was ousted
okay uh this this depart where I always
ask myself what is Tucker's Vision does
Tucker want to go follow a Netanyahu
Churchill type of a model as a
journalist who has been imagine if you
are someone that's been in journalism
and debate for the last 30 years 20
years and all you do is read every
single story who else knows the story is
better than you for 20 30 years and
you're charismatic and you got a
personality and you're a True Believer
and you're on debate States you've been
debating for 20 30 or it's not like you
don't have a way of doing it but it's
gonna it'll be interesting to see what
happens in Israel but also at the same
time I think
you know Tucker has to answer a question
does he want to be the Netanyahu
Churchill of U.S we'll see what happened
there I want to wrap up the podcast with
1101 did you want to say one final I'll
just say one thing you're talking about
the U.S and how we there there is
conversations within the United States
right now because how that's applicable
to us as a major Ally
um Joe Biden has not invited Bibi
Netanyahu to the White House he did
um invite president itzak Herzog is his
name uh to meet with him so there is
this pulling of the strings here you
know Trump has famously touted I'm the
most pro-israel president ever we know
that he said that a million times so
we'll see how this shakes out on the
coming of the 24 election if it is Biden
if it is Trump where you know a lot of
Republicans are basically calling out
Biden there is that sort of delicate
dance happening in Congress and to be
fair the day Biden won one of the first
people to tweet world leaders to tweet
out congratulations congratulations
and people like oh I can't believe he
did that because he wanted him he didn't
want Trump even some of the Trump Royals
were not happy about that but Netanyahu
players Jonathan Netanyahu and Trump
have a closer relationship than Biden
sure but at the end of the day
presidents come and go and the Israeli
U.S Alliance it's just funny the fact
that Biden hasn't made an effort anyways
we are at the end of the podcast uh
Thursday uh uh uh we will let you know
what's going to happen on the Thursday
part originally we weren't going to do
Thursday because I was going to go to
the uh the card collection convention
that's happening this week unfortunately
I will not be able to go out but I do
want to wrap it up with some of you guys
that are watching this content and you
have you're somebody that's on the
business side and you want to be doing
you know on the business and spend a
couple days with us on strategy we have
the Vault conference that's coming up uh
it'll sell out this week August 30th to
September 2nd myself Tom Brady Mike
Tyson will get there on 3 thousand other
people that are entrepreneurs executive
sales people that want to take their
business and their lives to the next
level if you haven't yet registered Co
tickets gone founder tickets gone
executive tickets gone the only ones
that are left are platinum in general
and right now if you buy a ticket you
get the second one 50 off click on a
link to get registered for us to see you
at the Vault conference in Miami Vinnie
will be there Tom will be there Adam may
be there we don't know yet what's going
on but uh our crew will be here we can't
wait to see all of you guys at the Vault
conference with that being said uh gang
we will do this again on Thursday take
care everybody bye-bye bye-bye
David here from the Italian pbd podcast
look once a year we host a conference
called The Vault conference it's our
Super Bowl where 3 000 entrepreneurs
CEOs executive sales people from around
the world come together to spend three
and a half days together from August
30th to September 2nd at the Diplomat
Resort in Miami to learn how to scale
their business how to identify their
next 5 10 15 moves who to recruit next
who to go raise their money from how to
raise Capital how to properly skill
culture retention higher fire all of
those things and much more and we do
that over a span of three and a half
days and the reason why it's a very
important season to attend a conference
like this the following reason today
there's three different types of people
they're scared they're those that are
content and the obsessed they're scared
they don't want to do anything because
they're worried about what's going to
happen in the economy they're going to
take a big hit the content they're
walking on saying life is pretty okay I
don't need to do anything else and then
there's the obsessed because they see a
massive opportunity today so imagine
spending three and a half days with
three thousand obsessed people that want
to grow in a season like this imagine
how much you can run from just those
relationships and networks so on top of
the people that are going to be
attending at this event this is probably
the best lineup we'll ever have out of
all conference Tom Brady seven time
Champion I'll be interviewing him he'll
be at the Vault conference Mike Tyson
will gudara the gentleman who ran the
restaurant 11 Madison New York that went
from a regular restaurant to a one
Michelin star two Michelin star three
Michelin stars and eventually the number
one restaurant in the world he's going
to talk about how they treat their
customers so look if you've not
registered yeah this is my
recommendation to I never went to
conferences when I was coming up by
myself I always went with a spouse with
a business partner or running mate
because I only have a lens on what I see
every night afterwards we would sit
there and say what was your biggest
takeaway so get yourself your spouse
your partner your running mate
registered to come spend three and a
half days with us at the Diplomat Resort
in Miami from August 30th to September
2nd I will see you there
foreign